salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche
c'est le jour de l'explication de la semaine
vous le savez
le mental vlog
c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
et le dimanche je vous explique
quelque chose qui va vous permettre
de bluffer votre familles ou vos amis
et cette semaine
je vais vous donner une explication
pour pouvoir deviner
le résultat de plusieurs dés
OK c'est parti
pour l'explication en direct
aujourd'hui pas de démonstration
parce que c'est pas possible vous n'êtes pas là en fait
là j'ai besoin de vous pour faire la démonstration
donc je vais vous l'expliquer
vous demander à un ami
de prendre 2 dés
il doit additionner les 2 faces dans sa tête
soit les vôtres soit les siens peut importe
durant toute la durée de l'expérience
vous ne devez pas voir ce qu'il fait c'est très important
donc vous pouvez même demander à quelqu'un de mettre ses mains devant vos yeux
pour qu'on soient sur et certain que vous ne trichiez pas
donc votre ami jette les 2 dés
une fois qu'il a jeté les 2 dés il doit additionner les 2 faces
dans sa tête dans son esprit sans le dire à personne
là ça fait 4 et 5 ça fait 9
ensuite votre ami doit prendre un des 2 dés
n'importe lequel
et regarder le chiffre qu'il y a sous le dés
donc si je soulève le 4
ici en dessous il y a le 3
et il doit aussi l'additionner à son résultat de départ
donc là on était à 9 on rajoute le 3
et enfin le dé qu'il a dans les mains
il doit le lancer une autre fois encore sur la table
et additionner le résultat
de ce dé qu'il vient de relancer
a son résultat initial
donc nous ça fait 3 + 12 ça fait 15
et il a 15 en tête
mais il n'y a que lui qui le sais vous vous ne pouvez pas le savoir
vous vous retourner a ce moment là
ou vous ouvrez les yeux
vous vous retourner vous regarder les 2 dés
et instantanément vous pouvez savoir qu'il a le nombre 15 en tête
la technique est simple c'est quelque chose que tout le monde ne sait pas
ou que tout le monde n'identifie pas en tous cas
dans ce processus là
c'est que l'addition de faces opposés d'un dés fait toujours 7
donc derrière le 5 on a le 2
ça fait 7
derrière le 3 on a le 4
et derrière le 1 il y a le 6 ça fait 7
et c'est sur cette astuce là
et sur cette astuce là que vous allez pouvoir déterminer ça à l'avance
donc je vous récapitule
la personne jette les 2 dés
et additionne dans sa tête
les 2 faces
ensuite elle choisit un des dés
n'importe lequel vous savez pas lequel
et elle va additionner à son 1er résultat
le nombre qu'il a sous le dé
la par exemple sous le 2 c'est le 5
et ce dé là qu'elle a dans la main
elle va le relancer
et additionner le résultat
de cette relance
à son nombre initial
et vous en vous retournant
vous savez le nombre
et a faire c'est très simple pour vous
vous avez juste à additionner
la face des 2 dés
qui sont visibles quand vous vous retourner
et à ajouter 7
puisque''on lui a fait ajouter 2 faces opposés
à un moment donné on lui a fait ajouter 7 en fait
vous pouvez le faire avec 3 dés dans ces cas là
vous en faites relancer 2
par exemple
et vous aurez à rajouter 14
au résultat final
c'est vous qui voyez
vous faites ce que vous voulez avec cette technique là
je vous laisse les pistes ouvertes
vous en faites ce que vous voulez
vous vous amuser avec
bluffer les gens avec
par contre n'oublier de me dire dans les commentaires
comment ça c'est passé
est ce que vous avez eu des difficultés
est ce que ça a bluffer des gens
est ce que vous avez une anecdote marrante
vous pouvez regarder toute les autres vidéos qu'il y a sur la chaine
on est à 72 vidéos
aujourd'hui il y en aura 366 en tout
donc abonnez vous à la chaine venez me voir en spectacle
passer un excellent dimanche et rendez vous
demain 17h
pour le prochain Mental Vlog chao